ok problèmes de doublure simp t manque de
correspondance et il y a du bruit à la
tête c'est ce que j'ai vu deux
générations une avec un mauvais son donc je le
regarde comme ça tu sais
parce qu'il y a trois endroits qui ressemblent
à eux  ne transmettra pas donc je lui
donne le nous devrons peut-être faire trois
autres plans ici, euh mec il y
avait un réalisateur qui a tourné 180 minutes
c'est trois minutes et 40 secondes
il avait un concept qui était très
expansif je  avait un concept était très
simple, il m'a permis de le modifier afin que
j'ai réussi à retirer mon concept de son
film nous avions quatre vidéos différentes, nous
aurions pu le découper de quatre manières différentes
pour moi certaines choses ne se couperaient pas avec
lui au départ pourquoi pas  mais il y a comme
par exemple dans la première demi-heure
il y avait une performance sur la
route c'était le tout début pour moi c'est
comme un test d'écran beaucoup d'épaules
tremblaient très vous savez l'attitude et la danse
et vous pourriez vous pourriez le faire de cette façon
mais la façon dont je l'ai toujours vu était m  plus
comme un film où cela ressemble plus à un
soliloque le séparant de la musique,
donc bien qu'il soit chanté, il ressemble à une
tête parlante parlant au lieu d'une
tête parlante chantant, donc vous optez pour
une méthode de performance cinématographique agissant
par opposition à un film muet à plan plus large
jeu gestuel donc il y a comme
vous le savez 180 minutes à 340 vous avez un
très bon type de nez dur donc ce que j'ai
fait était que je collais à peu près à l'
intimité de la voix principale avec des
gros plans et un peu illustré j'ai
essayé de dire  l'histoire du mieux
possible, donc c'est un peu sur moi d'une
manière comme mais euh
ouais nous en sommes tous contents
je veux dire euh il y a certaines
choses parce que dans ma propre photographie je suis
comme dans deux mondes bien l'album  art
tu sais comme deux images occupant la
même chose donc un fondu enchaîné est plus qu'un
fondu enchaîné pour moi tu sais c'est comme si ça allait
aussi comme une seconde en vidéo est plus grande
qu'une seconde en moi est plus petite qu'une
seconde et la musique vraiment toi  sais que je veux dire
mus  ic comme disons disons qu'une seconde
équivaut à trente images en vidéo, une mesure dans la musique
pourrait être de vingt et une images et vous pouvez
jouer des notes de trente secondes dans une mesure afin que vous
puissiez entrer dans une division musicale plus fine
que vous ne le pouvez en une seconde de  la vidéo, donc j'ai l'
habitude de travailler dans de petites mesures, vous
savez, comme et les fondus enchaînés et dans
ma façon dont j'édite est vraiment peu orthodoxe, je
mets mes coupes dures en dernier, vous savez, tous
les fondus enchaînés, la musique a beaucoup de
Shh, donc  vous mettez tout cela en premier
, puis vous revenez et mettez bien les
rythmes brillants, ce qui est généralement considéré comme
une sorte de perte de perspective
non, vous ne le faites pas de cette façon, vous mettez vos
coupes dures en premier, puis vous savez
aimer et se dissout  les gens ne les
considèrent même pas comme artistiques, ils les
considèrent comme une sorte de dernier recours en cas de
doute, dissolvez-vous, vous ne pouvez pas trouver une bonne coupe,
vous savez, donc cela prend un certain temps pour obtenir
euh mais de toute façon malgré  toutes ces
différences et les bosses que tu dois
surmonter comme si elle avait perdu ses billes
t  De cette manière, vous savez, nous avons finalement trouvé
quelque chose que nous aimons tous, mais au cours du
processus, nous avons eu des problèmes techniques en ligne
et c'est ce dont je veux être
sûr, car euh l'image au
début avait beaucoup de bruit et nous avions aussi du
nombre  problèmes juste au même
endroit, donc ma question est beurk devons-
nous relayer cela ou quoi
alors que faisons-nous bien
ouais
au moins ils ont testé les tonalités parce que nous
avions le son de cette copie que j'ai ramenée à la maison
la nuit dernière ouais frère et huez-moi
c'était  comme affreux donc ils ont dû faire
ça aujourd'hui oh non ça doit
quand même se rappeler qu'ils sont venus
c'est un peu le Barnett Newman
ok on y va moi du son
vois le bruit qui n'est pas bon c'est sur la
première génération d'
accord
Oh
nous avions  un cœur
oh mon Dieu
on y va
oh ouais
c'était juste un commentaire
Oh
je sens ta jambe
Oh des
feux de joie dans mon style
qui est ici
Oh
tu y
vas
oh ouais
Oh
c'est beau j'espère juste que tu sais que tu as
fait du bon travail
oh merci bien  monsieur vraiment c'est
super que  k vous
ouais vous ouais ouais un réel intérêt comme sur
les cadrans de couleur et c'est comme cette
chaleur qui entre et ils ont
aimé comme un fondu enchaîné dans la mer nous avons rencontré
des problèmes techniques là aussi parce que
nous sommes arrivés à nous l'avons fait hors ligne
tout  c'était bien d'arriver à la dernière
scène où vous avez les prises de vue
du col parce que nous avons fait quatre prises
et un gros plan à droite les deux premières ont été
vissées dans le bain d'impression l'imprimante a
imprimé une fuite le bain car le film était
trop sombre donc il  était inutilisable et
j'étais reconnaissant de penser que tout le monde
transpirait, je dis ne vous inquiétez pas stand
180 minutes tout ce qui meurt est une bonne
nouvelle vous savez alors la couleur
revient à la fin et c'était bien alors
nous l'avons faite noire-  et blanc en dehors de cela, nous l'
avons sur 2 rouleaux couleur et
noir et blanc, sauf ces longues
étendues de gros plan, la
durée de tension américaine étant modifiée vers le
bas, vous savez comme si vous composiez bien la
couleur à travers elle quand  nous sommes arrivés
au dernier coup quelque chose s'était passé  ed
où, lorsque vous avez apporté la couleur à
travers toute la tête, vous êtes devenu flou
, vous ne l'avez pas fait hors ligne, comme si en ligne,
cela devrait être mieux, mais ça a l'
air pire, alors quand vous examinez
s'ils découvrent que le col et le
noir et  blanc la tête du col est
légèrement plus petite que Dieu sait pourquoi
techniquement dans le transfert
vers la fin la tête rétrécit à droite
le psychiatre prend toute la tête
au milieu et maintenant quand vous allez aimer la
faire passer à travers tous les bords flous
au lieu qu'il s'agisse de deux plans identiques
qui se traversent l'un en couleur, l'autre
en noir et blanc, la couleur est
plus petite, donc tous les bords du visage sont
flous, donc je ne sais pas,
il y a beaucoup de choses qui se passent  Je
ne sais pas comment ils se produisent maintenant que le bleu
signifiait qu'il faisait trop chaud que quand il commence à se
briser en bleu rose vif, il fait trop
chaud et il pourrait être dans ce moniteur pour
laisser cet espoir parce que je vais le mettre
parce que je  dire aux gens qu'il n'y a
rien  ing mais le rebond qui aime
au début le bruit comme ça ça
ne vous dérange pas juste de voir l'image
et de voir l'histoire juste excellente et
puis je suis prêt à être interviewé car à l'
intérieur d'aller dans une interview
ça l'a inquiété parce que des coups  à l'extérieur sur cette route
ou incroyable, voyez absolument que nous avons eu des
heures de mauvais parce que vous pouvez faire une
vidéo entière là-bas, vous savez, mais c'est une
attitude complètement différente, vous savez que c'est
plus dansant et des trucs bien, vous aviez simplement l'
habitude de danser ce qui pourrait faire mal
ouais  vous êtes d'accord, ils ont l'
habitude de vous mesurer pas en 57 comme aux
danses de l'école mais je veux être trop
proche
ouais ils ne le sauraient pas parce que comme une
danse publique vous savez que tout le monde
attrape le cul vous savez mais les danses de l'école
ils se tenaient là avec une règle
et il devait marcher vous savez qu'ils étaient
toujours de la mentalité des murs Donna
digne et ainsi de suite quand la torsion est
sortie les gens je veux dire qu'il n'en fallait pas beaucoup pour
être choquant au
visage c'était mieux  Je pense que d'une certaine manière, c'était une
nouvelle période utile, il n'y a rien que vous sachiez
ce que Madonna va faire, coup de castor, et
puis quoi de neuf, c'est mon
gang, quelle que soit la tenue d'une interview,
fermée à 40 degrés comme ce
truc de famille bruyant, d'
accord.  ça se marie vraiment bien oh montre juste à
Joanie les couleurs John j'en ai fait un mon
inquiet qui bipe c'est là tu sais
je
t'ai vu personne cette nuit ouais et je
peux me tromper je viens de violettes c'est ma
couleur la moins préférée c'est vraiment sympa
avec ce bleu  gris que vous aviez, je choisis
parce que sans cela, cela semble
pire que l'offre de quatrième génération
et c'est notre majeur, vous savez que vous pourriez le
faire correctement, ils devraient vraiment devenir
réalistes, ils le regardent d'accord oh nous
devons faire un couple ne magasinez pas  merci
Merci prochaine chaîne de montage Oh toujours en mode
ça s'appelle la logique Marche pendante
c'est bien en gros tout ce dont j'ai besoin que tu
veuilles ici J'ai un film traditionnel
euh ouais dans ce domaine
pourquoi as-tu apporté ce cendrier ouais
plus bizarre que celui-là  avant
ouais très aller de l'avant pour passer à la télévision d'
accord voyons ce que nous avons juste
sortir un peu plus la tête de cette façon
ouais voilà et un de plus
laissez-moi refaire celui-là le plus long
soixante seul coup et demi quelque chose
légèrement pendant que nous '  j'attends je veux les
voir alors quand tu danses dans une autre
salle de contrôle ouais l'
as-tu utilisé pour quoi que ce soit ouais était-ce que
nous utilisions le temps 200 c'était je ne me suis jamais assis
Je te fais
des tirages oh d'accord je n'en ai pas tu
ne sais pas bien peut-être qu'ils en ont un
quelque part ouais les amis en ont un quand nous
irons ensuite Dora
s'ennuie un peu
16/3 d'
accord nous tirerons 16
amenez ces gars-là  partout où
tu vas ici ouais c'est mon entourage d'accord
et c'est bon ouais c'est bon avec ta
tête comme ça c'est bon et je sens que tu tiens
ça et la tête par ici toi camion
camion je suis en faveur de ce côté si ça
ne te dérange pas d'accord
pas de problème content que tu me l'ai dit ouais
tout le monde a la mort entière ouais ouais  h
tant de 1200 pouvez-vous en faire certains pouvez en faire
avec vos mains en quelque sorte écartées
ouais voilà ouais c'est bien non je ne suis
pas seul ok
maman essaie tout ce que tu veux faire
avec celui-là à mon périmètre  J'espère que tu t'y
étais penché ouais ouais là
c'est ça il
y a quelques personnes mais si beaucoup
de gens sont là
je ne vois pas combien de oh shoot il
y a un bâtiment ce n'est pas solitaire c'est deux
personnes qui s'entrechoquent comme certains  gros
Oz faisons-le beaucoup de gens sont
là c'est tellement heureux tu sais que c'est
comme si le studio avait une si bonne ambiance
autour de toi apporte ton autre main à
sa chambre de possession comme une chambre tu
sais d'accord presque fini ici nous avons
j'allais dire qu'un
éventail étonnant de personnes vous citent comme
une grande influence sur eux lorsque Prince et
les remplaçants un gars en Angleterre que nous
venons d'interviewer la semaine dernière, sceau et chanteur de R&B
, je me demandais si cela vous a surpris
et je veux aussi te demander ab  une
remarque Prince Edward spécifiquement il a
appris à utiliser la couleur en
écoutant vos chansons vous savez quelle couleur a besoin
de vous bien vous voyez euh mon harmonie
parce qu'ils ouvrent des accordages j'ai 50
accordages différents je ne joue pas en
accordage standard sur la guitare  la raison pour
laquelle j'ai choisi cela parce que l'harmonie
que j'entends dans ma tête et qui
sort au piano, je n'ai pas une
main gauche très facile, donc pour simplifier mon
art de la main gauche, je suis passé à ces accords maintenant
la blague tout au long des années 60  c'était si
j'étais chez quelqu'un et que je
prenais sa guitare bien sûr je la
mettrais dans un accordage ils la reprendraient
après moi ils iraient oh les martiens sont passés
ici vous savez les accords bizarres de
Joanie l'Harmonie était  pas agréable
pour beaucoup de gens c'était étrange pour beaucoup
de gens pour moi c'était un diagramme de mes
émotions qui étaient complexes les temps
étaient complexes vous savez pensez-y
la guerre froide avec la menace de la
bombe atomique c'est c'est dissonant  drone pour
moi c'est y  ous passe une bonne journée mais les
bombes pendent au-dessus il a mis un accord majeur
qui signifie belle journée mais tu as mis une
dissonance une deuxième note traversant
que
la bombe plane sur nous tu sais donc
aucune de mes émotions n'était purement simple
elles étaient toutes mes  la vie a été menée
dans un contexte de catastrophe imminente avec
laquelle je me réveille et m'endors avec elle
tous les soirs apocalypse Joan ils m'appellent
ainsi donc cela entre dans mon sens de l'
harmonie
que les gens à tort rock-and-rollers
ne pouvaient pas jouer ces accords  et les jazzers vers
qui j'ai dû me tourner pour jouer ce
ne sont pas non plus des accords de jazz,
donc le Jazz pose un accord dessus il a
déjà un peu changé l'harmonie
quand les gens disent que ma musique est du jazz j'ai fait
un disque de jazz qui était avec Mingus
megasis  la musique c'est du jazz mais mon harmonie n'importe quel
jazz ou italien n'est pas comme dirait Wayne
Shorter eh bien
ce ne sont pas des
accords généraux et ce ne sont pas des accords de guitare
quels sont ces accords c'est ce qu'il a
dit sur l'Éthiopie qui est et  Je vous connais
donc l'harmonie comme un peintre quand vous
venez d'opposer couleur contre couleur si vous
utilisez des couleurs de même valeur vous créez
une vibration vous faites la même chose quand
vous obtenez c'est l'art de l'affiche du 62e Alec vous
exécutez une seconde pour votre musique vous obtenez  la
même chose quand j'étais à l'école d'art j'ai
dit de ne jamais utiliser des couleurs de la même valeur les
unes à côté des autres car elles provoqueraient
une vibration Wow
deux ans plus tard l'art de l'affiche de San Francisco
est sorti ma dissonance azar l'
équivalent audio ils irritent les gens
vous savez et ils signifient un
irritant qui traverse une journée ensoleillée, donc prince
était très jeune quand il a eu sa chanson d'
été Lon's, il était ouvert d'esprit
Liang et où c'était chronologiquement le
temps pour la plupart de mon groupe de pairs
de me quitter parce qu'ils  J'ai adoré le disque
avant qui a créé des attentes dans
l'esprit de la plupart des Américains que le disque a échoué, mais en
anglais, c'était l'Angleterre et dans les estampes ici
en Amérique en Angleterre avec de jeunes artistes
sortant de l'école d'art Thomas Dolby
était  capable d'entendre ce disque avec un
esprit ouvert, il y en avait certaines, mon
public féminin ici a soudainement pensé que je leur
prenais des coups parce que j'ai
commencé à vous dire beaucoup au lieu
de beaucoup, ce qui leur a donné une sortie oh elle
parle d'elle-même oh elle ne l'est pas
parler d'elle alors elle doit
parler de nous j'aime pas le
portrait c'est une garce tu sais donc tu
sais il y avait toutes sortes de complications
dans l'accueil dans cette culture de la
danse des pelouses d'été ça s'est
compliqué
pas tellement  en Angleterre où j'aime ça et
comme je le dis dans les estampes maintenant s'il a obtenu ses
couleurs à partir de là, nous parlons d'
idées harmoniques assez nouvelles euh des beurres de jazz sombres des
accords grands ouverts comme le jazz mais
ils n'appartiennent pas à l'idiomatique vous
savez que j'ai  un ami qui jouait avec moi
parfois qui a littéralement écrit le livre
sur l'harmonie du jazz et il jouait sur euh
c'était quoi le nom de la chanson qui voit
la lune bleue à la fenêtre et il
devenait de plus en plus fou et de plus en plus fou et
finalement j'arrête  ped la bande et je lui ai
dit Victor ce qui ne va pas tu sais tu n'aimes pas
le mot je déteste l'harmonie il a
dit ma petite amie Debbie je déteste l'
harmonie tant de gens je déteste qu'il
va soit tu l'aimes soit tu ne l'aimes pas
ces ces accords étranges
s'ils ne correspondent pas s'ils vous correspondent émotionnellement
ha ils sont vraiment soulagés parce qu'ils
dépeignent vos sentiments s'ils ne le font pas ou si
ça change vous avez vous êtes au
bord de et ne voulez pas  pour traverser,
vous le détesterez, vous savez, donc ce
serait la dernière question que j'ai lue dans une interview
avec le réalisateur Rob Reiner où il a
dit que les gens pensent que cela devient plus facile une fois que
vous avez réussi, mais
qu'il pense en fait que c'est beaucoup plus difficile parce que
quand  vous avez juste du mal à aller de l'avant,
personne n'a rien à quoi vous comparer,
mais une fois que vous avez eu une mesure de
succès, il y a toujours la pression de
tout le monde au moins pour correspondre à
ce que vous avez fait dans le passé, vous pensez
que c'est vrai  - bien - deux choses d'abord
la meilleure citation sur t  ce que j'ai entendu était tellement
carburant qui a dit assez fort pour attraper
le tigre plus difficile encore pour le monter, vous
savez,
je ne rivalise avec personne et non
et je ne rivalise pas contre moi-même
non plus, je veux dire d'une certaine manière, mes normes ne cessent de
croître  donc j'ai une chose externe que
j'essaie d'atteindre et bien que la critique
puisse me déranger suffisamment, vous savez pour
me donner une mauvaise journée ou quelque chose,
surtout parce qu'une grande partie est si
ignorante que vous voulez les appeler et
dire que vous savez  vous ne savez pas comment je ne sais pas
lumen à quel point vous vous trompez vous savez que
vous voulez les éduquer mais vous pouvez
parce qu'ils y sont attachés et si
vous avez essayé de le faire si cela échoue
physiquement la chose la plus difficile à éduquer
les gens sont une qualité de la nature humaine en
supposant que vous ayez eu un bon rendez-vous vous obtenez une
super fille merveilleuse merveilleuse mangez tous
vos amis vous permettent ce
vendredi prochain vous en avez un autre à venir oh
vous pouvez à peine attendre vous savez comme vous
juste quand vous y arrivez  ça pourrait même être
mieux que ton premier  date mais vous
ressentirez cela comme moins parce que vos
attentes se sont tellement développées dans le
processus et bien c'est ce qui se passe
psychologiquement comme si cet album semble
que les gens vont l'adorer ils
vont détester mon prochain vous savez ou
ils sont  ne va pas autant l'aimer
parce qu'une attente sera mise en place donc
la meilleure chose que je puisse faire avec mon
prochain sachant ce modèle comment je
regarde me jeter une courbe maintenant c'est le
modèle que j'ai vécu je suis ouvert à  une
exception mais je ferai probablement
un prochain album assez expérimental c'est un bon
moment pour s'étirer c'est un bon moment pour
s'étirer vous savez sachant que
c'est différent
j'ai vu cela se produire avec Asia et Gaucho
vous pourriez probablement inverser ces deux
albums  Gaucho était un si bon album était
tellement sous-évalué, vous savez probablement
parce que celui d'avant était tellement aimé, vous savez que les
critiques de gaucho étaient dérisoires
par rapport à ce que c'était que quelqu'un
puisse faire deux disques d'affilée c'est
fort que complet  e que vous connaissez deux
bons albums, pas seulement deux bonnes
collections de chansons, pas même seulement deux
morceaux avec quelques bonnes chansons, vous
savez,
donc j'ai vu cela arriver à d'autres personnes
ainsi qu'aux miens, vous savez que mes
projets dans lesquels nous vivons  une société
qui est devenue incontrôlable sur le
facteur de nouveauté, vous savez, comme si elle ne
cessait de prendre de l'avance sur elle-même, vous savez,
le fait de se fatiguer du nom d'une personne ou de
se fatiguer du regard d'une personne et d'arrêter de
voir arrêter de voir que Michael Jackson
est un  brillant danseur arrête de voir ses
mouvements whoa
tu sais comme même s'il continue de
progresser tu sais comme tu sais comme chaque
génération doit être plus choquante que
la suivante mais je pense que nous devrions commencer à
aller dans l'autre sens débarrassons-nous
d'un petit choc tu sais  comme ça, vous
savez, comme récupérer un peu de cœur dans la
culture, vous savez que je déteste ressembler à
une culture plus douce de Bush, vous savez, mais ce n'était pas une
mauvaise idée, vous savez, je veux dire, je pense que
nous avons perdu les années 80, il
manque à l'intelligence un  pièce sans  mais l'entreprise
peut être amicale, j'ai découvert que c'est
incroyable à quel point ce projet est agréable,
vous savez que l'entreprise est Plaza,
tout le monde est agréable, c'est une façon tellement plus
agréable de faire des affaires.
comme un bon
moment expérimental sur les relations dans les
années 90 parce que nous sommes allés trop loin dans un sens dans
les années 80 c'était comme si vous saviez que c'était trop
seul vous êtes dans des moments difficiles à venir les
gens l'ont compris vous savez se
renforcer et leur compassion parce que
nous avons  les moments difficiles arrivent d'accord c'est un
bon endroit pour s'arrêter Merci
pouvons-nous avoir la guitare ouais Oh en seconde
laissez-moi juste trouver quatre petits morceaux de
musique pour vous d'accord donc je vous montrerai des
petits morceaux après d'accord c'est
tellement la plupart de cet album  est dans cet accord
qui est pour les guitaristes qui regardent
ça, il est sept sept deux trois trois
cinq sept sept deux trois cinq avec une
goutte avec un sceau en bas donc c'est
surtout comme un accord en do majeur en conséquence
les chansons ont  une sorte de
modalité optimiste et bien entendre
cette
enquête d'enquête mineure d'accord de sorte que vous avez une
majeure en mineure et ajoutée, c'est comme
toujours ce que j'appelle des notes d'enquête et en
évitant la résolution de possibilité de doute d'enquête inquiétante de
sorte qu'une
émotion complexe n'est pas  t-il vous savez revenir à une pure
émotion simple compliqué joyeux
positif heureux c'est à peu près un
mineur avec une inversion mais celui-ci est
maintenant je ne connais pas le nom peut-être que c'est une
soucoupe je ne sais pas comme les
noms de l'alphabet des lettres de tout ça  des trucs mais donc
je l'identifie plus par la façon dont la cour
se sent venant du froid est voyons
comment ça se passe
oh ouais Cherokee Louise
le premier que nous éteignons juste un peu
mieux
toi d'
accord
ouais c'était un c'est un Steve
Kline précoce il  l'a fait, il a un très
petit nombre et tout le personnel est
que c'est l'hexagramme de l'enseignement pour
le vagabond il y a un étranger dans un
pays étrange d'où vient ce concept
et ce sont tous les
trigrammes de t  chacun d'
entre eux représente chacun le père, la
mère, les trois fils et les trois
filles qui, en combinaison,
créent les 64 changements divisés en six
que vous pouvez éventuellement traverser dans une
vie, puis le reste est
plutôt personnel.  mon mon serpent dans mon
aigle la nature haute et basse du
scorpion et puis c'est la
fleur provinciale de la saskatchewan d'où je viens
il a fait un beau travail merci beaucoup d'
accord super super